hey everybody I'm Scott Butterworth here
with gamespot.com the PlayStation
meeting was earlier today where they
finally unveiled the PlayStation neo
told us it's actually called PlayStation
pro so we have our technology editor
Jimmy thing here to talk about some of
the specs walk us through what this is
going to mean and really we're going to
kind of figure out if the console is
gonna be worth it for volume people out
there so hey Jimmy how's it going it's
going well yeah so you know as you
mentioned Sony you know unveiled the ps4
Pro previously known as the PlayStation
neo yeah we're gonna have to get used to
saying Pro now right and on the stage
they mentioned that it was two times as
powerful as the ps4 but we finally have
some concrete tech specs I just wanted
to walk you through them sure we have a
we're still using a AMD a system on a
chip SOC it's x86 so it's the same kind
of CPU architecture that you kind of
have in a typical PC on stage they
didn't mention teraflops but we do have
them
it's 4.2 teraflops collection heard -
are we gonna get into the Spokeo yes
that's a big question
less than Scorpios project Scorpios six
teraflops gotcha it's a based off of
AMD's polaris GPU architecture which is
the same GPU architecture that's used in
AMD's you know recently released our X
480 graphics card and it shares a lot of
similarities to like card two because it
also has the same amount of VRAM video
RAM and that's eight gigabytes of gddr5
memory gotcha
and so if we're using a the our X 480 as
sort of a point of comparison I know we
kind of talked off-camera about like
what does that mean yeah just for a
frame of reference if this was a gaming
PC what would these specs like where
would it kind of live in the spectrum so
as far as I can tell the closest thing
in the PC space is the RX 480 and that
is generally seen as a card that's like
really good for 1080p gaming it can do
like you can do a decent job handling
1440p which many you referred to as 2k s
before cake as for as for 4k however
it's not really known as a 4k capable
video card mmm but it can do 4k - you
know on some like lesser taxing games
interesting it's really interesting to
hear you say that it's not super built
for 4k because obviously sony was really
pushing that during the presentation and
talking about
the glory of 4k and like the depth of
color of HDR so I mean so what is this
actually going to mean then it will will
this not be you know for people out
there who actually own 4k televisions is
this going to perform the way they're
hoping we're expecting it will so you
know the ps4 Pro can do 4k but it it
Sony isn't mandating all game developers
right to push for K so that is an
important distinction to make um so you
know it's sort of a kind of a
wait-and-see as to which games will
support 4k we do have a small list I do
know that for honored ASX
rise of the Tomb Raider watchdogs to and
killing floor will support 4k gotcha but
this is purely a developer decision this
isn't going to be like all games going
forward it's just gonna be you know
these certain select titles are going to
you know develop will decide for
themselves if they're going to implement
this because it sounds like it's it's a
pretty demanding process I mean this is
not going to be something that's super
simple or easy for developers to
implement frankly I was really surprised
that they were going to actually you
know allow for native for case supports
2160p that's the resolution that's
actually four times as sharp and four
times as demanding as 1080p hmm but only
two times as powerful so I was a little
surprised by that
and so while not all games will support
4k many more games will support HDR
which stands for high dynamic range and
you will need a TV that supports HDR but
what this allows for is basically more
vibrant colors um and like richer blacks
the blacks will look blacker and this is
very noticeable you know and you know
obviously you will need a HDR TV for it
but beyond that it will actually help
out the ps4 Pro will actually a bolster
like 1080p gaming as well okay so even
if you don't own a 4k television if you
don't have own like the top-of-the-line
hi-def TV this the pro will actually
still help you or will improve display
yeah so Sony gave two examples of it
bolstering like just regular TVs or
maybe just like one and then psvr
example so the first one is them showing
off a far point which is you know psvr
title and that one is going to just
basically get better graph
improved fidelity so they're going to
use a processing power that way gotcha
the other one was a shadow of Mordor
which shone off using SSA a which is
super sampling anti-aliasing what that
does is it renders the image higher than
1080p and then it downsizes it to your
1080p TV gotcha
so it basically looks sharper it's not a
sharpest 4k but it is noticeably sharper
gotcha
one really interesting about the the
specs that I noticed there isn't
actually a physical 4k blu-ray player
it's just the standard blu-ray player is
that correct and why would Sony make
that decision yes so they didn't mention
that during the press conference so I
just kind of assumed you know of course
it has and then later we found out that
it actually doesn't which is very
surprising because even you know
Microsoft's Xbox 1s supports it um so
yeah I think that was probably a
cost-saving mushroom but it is kind of
strange for Sony to push this as like a
4k you know HDR player but it doesn't
have the actual physical drive right you
can you know run efflux movies and
things like that yeah I suppose that
would sort of be the the
counter-argument to this right so it the
PlayStation Pro only cost 400 bucks
which is actually a very reasonable
price point it's only $100 more than the
standard ps4 and yeah they were pushing
like you know they mentioned that
Netflix there's going to be 600 hours
worth of 4k content available by the end
of the year so if you're just treating
it as a digital box the lack of a
physical media player actually doesn't
really matter so I mean I don't know if
that really excuses the absence of a
physical before K blu-ray player but I
mean at least you're not totally
stranded you have options right right
they also mentioned some other specs we
know the hard drive size it's gonna be
one terabyte I was hoping for an SSD but
that's kind of wishful thinking cuz this
is these are pretty expensive it's
probably 5400 rpm drive and I was hoping
for 7200 rpm but it is again cheaper we
did get the dimensions as well it's kind
of larger look yeah it's like a beefy
box it's a it's a pretty substantial
piece of hardware so when I saw I think
was Andrew house was holding it at the
end I wasn't sure if the box was big or
he's just a really small mini but the
dimensions are eleven point six by two
point one by two
of inches so it is pretty sizable yeah
and I think you said it weighs like what
seven seven point two pounds which is
quite a bit more than the ps4 right
right but in a way that makes sense
because I mean it's housing some
certainly a more substantial hardware
than the traditional ps4 sure sure so it
might be too early to say I mean there's
still more that we need to learn about
this but based on what we know so far do
you think that the PlayStation Pro
justifies the price do you think it's
worth deported all the price tag that's
that's a good question I do think that
it is priced fairly and I think if you
don't own a Playstation 4 and you've
been waiting for a reason I think this
is a good reason and then if you have a
ps4 I would say unless you have a 4k HDR
TV I would hold out gotcha
and of course you know you can expect
more coverage from it as we get it in as
well yeah I'm sure we're gonna get a
full breakdown comparison of the Pro
versus the Scorpio and all kinds of fun
hardware stuff so yeah stay tuned to
games.com for more hardware coverage
from Jimmie thang and more on basically
everything GameSpot comm
[Music]
you
[Music]